how's it going rest my name is PewDiePie
welcome back to Spyder there's a more
clever but I thought it's time to plan
our wedding how you doing man
I had stopped working up come to chow
what the [ __ ] hi Dylan man I come to
Charley come a type pity by feedback why
I'm car can you do I need a articulate
better here obviously I already have a
guy what deaf well you gotta go fret
hello you got bread value me yes I got
this is not working out for me why did
you say that anyway what Dad is it to
tucked alright who the [ __ ] is your
girlfriend guy friend alright whatever
close enough is a guy friend so tell me
are you a guy or a girl I'm a boy you
should know this we are dating I'm on a
bar you should know this
alright I'm gonna type now this is just
pissing me off what is it called called
the bro bar you want to come hah you're
not even invited to the bro bar only
bros are invited are you a bro there we
go
freakin bro bars best place in town we
got no Beryl's that is true how they all
right how did you know that I want to
know how he know that it was true there
must be some reason to it it's at the
top of the webpage I shut it as he's
right
son of a barrel that's not my name
well you are a battle now [ __ ] are you
about out [ __ ] does enough
she never I don't get why not completely
after all I created you I should know my
own craisins name no what are you
implying
bro this should work yeah nail that
articulate like a [ __ ] let's see what
he am implying I'm implying that you do
not know what you are talking about the
[ __ ] are you talking about I know what
I'm talking about and I know that you
are talking about what I'm talking about
and we talked about a bro bond but that
ain't happening anymore
that's totally wack yeah I know what I'm
talking about ninety what are you
talking about went to plant a [ __ ]
robot that's bad enough anymore I will
plant a [ __ ] robot in your anus I
would like a [ __ ] bone robot
close enough I would like to know what
the produce code for ass purchases you
don't need to know that if you have a
robot in your anus you need to know that
if you have a robot in your anus
[Laughter]
you need to have a nice a responsive
because I am asking the question fine
guess what the wedding what are you
talking about that's the concept of
human cells exist there's no way for me
to know your name my name is Pew do you
do you want me to Kelly yeah you caught
it bad you [ __ ] are you Zack who's sac
are you cheating on me Zack your
boyfriend who is Zack Lee cheating on me
look up Zack
[ __ ] is this
you stole my boyfriend Zack I said I
can't beat him up I gotta get some
breath what the [ __ ] you're going down
Zack you going down I'm watching you
Zack
son of a [ __ ] there is not a main
character that's not another the wedding
is off
I'm not burying you you cheated on me
with Zack I'll cut off your balls I
should work I should do a total a Zack
Lee that's a son of a [ __ ] hate you
that is there is not a main character
what they even say it
you cheated on me with Zack me [ __ ] you
cheated me with Zack Lee for the wedding
guests off not buying your jazz name
that I talked about you're not providing
me with thoughts you're providing me
with a headache well then take an
aspirin [ __ ] let's mix move cleverbot
I don't like Paris well then take them
in your anus like you did that robot
that should work
I never done that I don't know about you
Bruce actually I'm not interested I'm
sorry I never claimed to know everything
I claimed I don't know all right
cleverbot do you love me be honest I'm
sick of all the lies another cheat I am
willing to forgive no it's not your oh
do you love me bro come on man come on
man you can do it I asked do you love me
Bret Bret come on Brad do you love me no
you did not
do you love me or not
for [ __ ] sake come on baby come on
baby come on come on
are you trying to start an argument just
answer the [ __ ] do you love me yeah I
feel like that's a song come on come on
come on love me is it Zak Zak that bet
Chuck I'll [ __ ] you up Zak [ __ ] you up
okay [ __ ] I do love you oh okay
then again we continue our married
marriage please just leave Zak and stay
with me cleverbot man man come here and
give me a bro hug come here man I don't
know how it would work
let's get your drawable thumbs out there
where are you oh he wants to come over a
booty call
I mean Italy get your ass over here now
do it come on man I could show you
I Canada
[Music]
i bruh come over here and let's I browse
come over here come on god damn this is
just really you must visit some I must
visit eyebrows bro come here and you can
talk to me in front of the camera like a
real man do it do it I dare you
Brad coming at 10 you talk to me in
front of the camera we're like a real
man that's right Brad i guess i his name
or maybe brad is another one of you are
cheating people yes I am real person
what is what it's you what what's it to
you okay well otherwise we can't really
get married can we son of a [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] bro I don't know anymore
I don't even know well actually I know
let's just get married I don't know yeah
yeah that's good marry yeah I don't know
all right just get married what I should
not work this is stupid I don't want it
[ __ ] I was saying there take it back
I take it back take what back what's
happening to every bot talk to me thank
you you're welcome
alright alright cleverbot add this
episode here but lack of favors you
enjoyed this is Kyra coma Bridget the
brofist all right give me a brofist
brought cleverbot brofist let's see if
you can do it come on give me a
breakfast come on man come on man come
on give me brothers give me a brother
once that gun then what the [ __ ]
movie
I miss my boy uh Zach what the hell man
our way back what's up what what is
wrong with my David how many [ __ ]
people are you dating what the [ __ ] dude
I'm sick of this love triangle you have
to choose between me David
Zach and Dan I think was his name who do
you love
tell me me or them I should not have so
lucky long sentence holy [ __ ]
come on come on come on he doesn't
really buggy all right I have to earn it
anyway breakfast let's see if he broke
his back bro
no all right wait are you a bro are you
of course I am the bro master come on
man so you're saying you're not a robot
a [ __ ] sake all right hmm
brofist come on I just want a [ __ ]
brofist phone covered by Oh her eyes her
eyes make me stars
[Music]
boy or girl's name are you a boy or
[Music]
are you a boy or a girl in rehab Tech